comme on ne savait sans doute pas si
l'on devait exposer au salon nautique ou
au salon automobile
c'est non loin des 2 au pont de la
concorde que l'amphi car a été présenté
aux parisiens voiture amphibie mû par
deux hélices ou ne les voir ce véhicule
américain a été mise au point par des
ingénieurs allemands de l'ouest
recommandé pour la chasse au canard
l'amphi carré silencieux ou silencieuse
et se déplace sur l'eau à environ 15
kilomètres heure pour une consommation
horaire de 6 litres et demi sur route
son moteur 4 cylindres développe 43
chevaux est atteinte en pointe 130
kilomètres heure quatre passagers il
trouve un bon confort aux états unis
l'amphi carré vendu pour 17 mille de nos
anciens francs
bon
pour un couple qui vient de s'unir le
voyage de noces prête souvent à
discussion venise c'est banal tahiti
c'est un peu loin
ces jeunes mariés marseillais ont eu une
idée originale une croisière à bord du
télescope qui dans une calanque proche
de la capitale phocéenne vient d'entrer
en service à titre expérimental dérivés
d'été les bennes de nos stations de ski
le télescope a été imaginée par l'ancien
champion jams coûtait et réalisé par
l'ingénieur daniel crescent la promenade
900 m dix huit minutes sous une dizaine
de mètres d'eau
pro monde du silence n'est pas
nécessairement celui de la solitude
bientôt tout le monde pourra en tenue de
ville jouer les capitaines hainaut à 30
pieds sous la mer
à paris le grand palais a connu son
dernier salon où l'on cause cuisine
l'année prochaine en effet le salon des
arts ménagers émigrera au rond-point de
la défense avec son univers magique où
tout semble se faire tout seul et ses
innombrables machine qu'il a avec qui et
sort qu'ils font à volonté le chaud et
le froid
cette année 1500 exposants ont rempli le
grand palais or on prendre la défense
ils seront plus nombreux encore
puisqu'ils accueilleront des exposants
étrangers
aussi n'est-il pas inutile de pouvoir au
passage faire le point dans une
encyclopédie l'univers ménages est
aujourd'hui si fourni et nous grand mère
aurait été bien étonné d'apprendre que
leur bon vieux torchon de cuisine se
transformerait un jour en rouleaux de
papier
et si vous éprouvez une tentation
d'élégance vous pouvez vous composez un
collier avec ses berlingots de 6
voici une carte perforée l'une de ces
cartes que l'on utilise de plus en plus
dans diverses activités humaines
je voudrais demander monsieur le guen et
dalles qui est le directeur d'une grande
maison française fabriquant des machines
utilisant ces cartes perforées de nous
dire combien l'on consomme en france de
cartes perforées par an plus d'un
milliard par ambitieux 1 milliard oui
messieurs si vous dire que la carte
perforée maintenant est utilisé depuis
la petite entreprise jusqu'aux plus
grands ensembles industriels ou aux
grandes administrations de l'état à
point ça c est bien cela sert
essentiellement à dégager l'homme de
tous les travaux de plumes que jusqu'à
présent il fallait faire à la main et
d'autre part ces travaux auront l'effet
un million de fois plus vite si vous
voulez un ordre de grandeur et on les
répétera aussi souvent quand il voudra
la première opération qui devait de
tenir c'est quoi c'est la perforation de
la carte
la perforation de la carte qui est faite
sur cette machine et je voudrais vous
demander mademoiselle de bien vouloir
dire aux spectateurs
comment vous faites avec une carte
normale pour la perforer et bien
monsieur au vu d'un document de base
nous utilisons un clavier du type
dactylographique ces enseignements sont
pris sous un bloc de poissons et
reçoivent la perforation dans la carte
c'est à dire que en somme vous taper à
la machine mais au lieu de faire des
lettres vous fait d'être ou wind shear
voudriez vous nous prévoir madame
comment ça marche
cette jeune femme tape et voici la carte
perforée juillet sortie après quoi on la
prend délicatement et on va l'introduire
dans une autre machine que nous allons
l'assumer
eh bien monsieur cette carte dont vous
avez bien voulu agrandir le modèle pour
nous tout exprès permettrait de faire
quoi de trouver et de choisir par
exemple des personnes répondant à des
caractéristiques très précises et pour
être plus précis pour prendre un exemple
concret et bien un directeur d'école
pourrait attendre deux minutes sur ses
3000 élèves trouver ce qui rompt dix ans
au cours de cette année scolaire
oui qui pèse 40 kg qui ont une certaine
taille qui ont plusieurs frères et
soeurs et cetera et cetera et cetera et
cetera de façon à établir tous les
contrôles administratifs ou sanitaires
dont ils pourraient avoir besoin alors
voyons donc la carte de plus près il y a
plusieurs colonnes avec des perforations
la colonne du nom du prénom de la date
de naissance le sexe la taille le nombre
de paires et sert le poids la couleur
des cheveux la couleur des yeux et
cetera et cetera
alors lorsque il sait ce qu'il veut
choisir votre directeur d'école il n'a
plus qu'à mettre les cartes de tous ses
élèves dans votre machine qui priera
pour lui exactement
alors nous allons la voir fonctionner et
voici une trieuse électronique
celle qui prient les cartes perforées
les perforations des cartes sont
détectés par des petits balais
métallique en acier peint est spécial il
y à 80 balais dans chacun correspond à
l'une des 80 comme
la carte et ses ballets déclenché des
impulsions électriques etc impulsion à
leur tour commandes des aiguillages qui
dirigent des cartes vers des 15 choisi
au moyen du tableau commun composé d'une
grande quantité de fils électriques et
qui est en somme le cerveau de la
machine et voici le stade final cette
machine travaille à quelle vitesse
monsieur elle travaille elle choisit
l'écart à 7 cents à la minute et c'est à
dire que notre directeur d'école
trouverait dans une des 15 les élèves
qui correspondent aux caractérisant la
graine numéro 12 la dernière à gauche
voilà donc il y aurait dans l'exemple
choisi quatre élèves correspondantes aux
données qui intéressait le directeur
d'école merci messieurs
gomes la ville il a fallu atteindre que
le brouillard se lève pour présenter les
essais à grande vitesse de l'aérotrain
équipée d'un réacteur
le prototype à l'échelle 1/2 conçu par
l'ingénieur bertin devait atteindre la
vitesse fantastique de 345 kilomètres à
l'heure grâce à l'appoint de deux fusées
de 500 et plus de 100 kg de poussée
d'ici quelques années on ira ainsi de
paris à orléans en moins d'une
demi-heure pour l'instant la voie à de
courtes explique l'utilisation des
parachutes pour le freinage